CNN senior
national security correspondent
Alex Marquardt is back with us.
Alex,
we're hearing words
like nullified, humiliated.
These are words
that Vladimir Putin does not like.
What are some of
the diplomatic challenges
of dealing with a politically wounded
Vladimir Putin?
Huge diplomatic challenges, Jim.
Huge security challenges.
Remember, this is a man
who's in charge of the world's
biggest nuclear arsenal.
Any Putin watcher will tell you
that if Putin is backed into a corner,
that makes for a very dangerous Putin.
We have never seen
a challenge to his authority like this.
As you mentioned, these
these vagrant troops
getting within 125 miles, 200
kilometers of the Kremlin.
His weakness has been exposed.
And so he is going to have
to reassert himself
in a way
that demonstrates
to the world
and demonstrates to his country
that he is fully in power.
The US is going to have
to navigate this carefully,
and we're already starting
to see that outlet.
Touched on the fact that the U.S.
has had a very hands off approach
making clear,
trying to make clear to the world
that they really didn't
have any role in this,
that they certainly are not supporting.
Prigozhin on his march to Moscow
But Jim, at the same time,
obviously watching this very carefully
and we are told
that the intelligence community
did see this coming,
that in the past few days and weeks
they have really seen planning for this.
They've seen Wagner troops
getting into position,
equipment and weaponry on the move.
There was a briefing,
we're told,
midweek
by intelligence officials
to the Gang of Eight in Congress,
which includes the heads of the House
and Senate Intelligence Committees,
essentially telling them
that this was imminent.
Let's take a listen to Mike
Rogers, the head of the House
Intelligence Committee.
The Intelligence Committee
was very much aware
that the conflict
between Prigozhin
and Putin was inevitable.
This is not a weekend trip
he's taking,
taking his convoy
and his military convoy up to Moscow.
There's a number of accomplices,
including, as we saw,
some of the Russian people on the border
with Ukraine
who clearly support the group
in contrast to their support
for the Russian government.
This is something that would have had
to have been planned
for a significant amount of time
to be executed in the manner
which it was.
So that was Mike
Turner, the Republican head of the House
Intelligence Committee,
indicating that this was very much known
by the intelligence community.
Jim, what was not
expected was the lack of resistance
to these Wagner forces.
I'm told the U.S.
assessment
thought that there would be
a lot more violence, a lot more bloodshed
as Wagner tried to get head north
and get to the Russian capital.
All right.
Alex Marquardt,
thank you very much for that.
At this hour,
we still do not know where
Vladimir Putin is.
Ukrainian President Zelensky said
yesterday
the Russian leader
is, quote,
very afraid and was no longer in Moscow.
With me now is Yuri Soviet's.
He studied with Putin
at the KGB Institute
and worked as a Soviet spy in Washington.
Yuri,
thank you very much
for joining us tonight.
I can't imagine
there are a whole lot of folks out there
who might have better insights
into what has occurred
this past weekend than you do.
What do you think?
How do
you think Putin
is reacting
to reacting to this near insurrection
and at the same time?
Why isn't we?
Why is it that we have not seen Putin
since that angry statement
that he put out just about 24 hours ago?
Thank you for having me, Jim.
First.
I believe this is a disaster for Putin.
And he understands
he realizes this is a disaster.
And according to his practices
in similar situation, he digs into a hole
and stays there as long as possible.
This is what he is doing right now.
And
the last two days,
it was the final act of defeat of Putin.
Putin's image, which has been building
since the year 2000,
since the beginning of the aggression
into Ukraine.
He destroyed a reputation or
a myth
about the Russian army
being the second best in the world.
Now, this is the second army
in Russia after Wagner, apparently.
And over the last two
days, he showed that
his grip on power in
Russia is almost nonexistent.
He balances over the last 20 years,
his act was to balance
between different factions. He doesn't.
He doesn't do.
He is not in position to do it anymore.
He controls the country as a Mafia style
organization, and
she loves control.
This question is
how humiliating is it
for Putin
to be challenged
by someone like Prigozhin
that to essentially have forgotten
125 miles or so from Moscow,
somebody who was once his protege
Exactly. Exactly.
Because the
precautions especially
especially the betrayal of Prigozhin.
Because for Putin, it was a lap dog.
Prigozhin as a personality was created
by Putin essentially before.
Before they met
Prigozhin was a two time hardcore drug
criminal.
Hardcore criminal.
And this is Putin who made him very rich,
famous and powerful.
So Putin can see this as a real betrayal.
And if he is to say it in the past,
there is one crime
which he cannot pardon.
And this is a betrayal.
But this is what he did yesterday.
You know, just that he does it well.
Yeah.
What do you make of this deal
that they made?
They they made this deal where
Prigozhin gets to leave for Belarus
and his mercenaries
and Wagner
are folded into the Russian military
and that that is that all is forgiven.
Can you believe that?
Well, this is what not just so.
I cannot believe what I have.
Difficult to believe,
but most Russians hardly
clearly believe
because it's
there is a clear humiliation,
more and even more so, because what
we know so far is
this is an official part
of the arrangement.
But sources close to Kremlin,
they say that there is one very important
point of
the real arrangement,
which is not yet has not been announced.
And this is Shoigu, the defense minister
and the chief of staff
will go into retirement.
There will not be fires in disgrace
as a precaution demanded, but
they will be moving to retirement
that it was a single, explicitly
formulated demand of precaution.
And let me ask you this.
How is Putin
going to survive this politically?
We were talking about this
with other guests during this program
that I know
from Russian
history is the history
of the Soviet Union.
Generational change in Russia,
where the Soviet Union, for that
matter, can happen
very quickly,
very suddenly,
and take the world by surprise.
Do you
do you think something like
that could happen
and bring about the end of Vladimir Putin
It's hard to say
because Putin's personnel policy over
the 20 years in power was to nominate
among
his subordinates
people who are not intelligent,
not they have no guts there.
Most of them have no entities, let's say
So there is like,
you know,
like Gray my my assistants,
he used to say.
So it's hard to imagine that these people
can commit a coup d'état.
Prigozhin two times convicted criminal
Putin's chef.
He dared to do this
by the high ranking military FSB
They they they did it there.
So the country is right
now is basically in a freefall.
I mean, in terms
that the system of control
and governance is almost destroyed.
I don't know how
they are going to repair this.
But what is important to understand
in similar circumstance Putin's threat
tactic is to fight back with threats
bluff.
Most of them
also stress
bluffing, such as,
you know, brandishing nuclear weapons.
Tactical use of tactical.
No use of nukes in Ukraine or elsewhere.
I can tell you on the basis of one
professional experience,
this is the bluff
which goes back to the days of the KGB.
Very interesting.
All right.
Well,
and you would know that subject well.
Yuri Chavez,
thank you very much for joining us.
We'd love to have you back and continue
having this conversation.
It's very important.
Thanks very much for your time.
It's going get for everything.
All right. We appreciate it.
Amid the chaos in Russia,
Ukraine's
military says it is gaining ground
around the city of Baquba.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh is in key for us.
Nick,
Ukraine clearly wants to capitalize
on this power struggle in Russia.
Can they do that?
Yeah, that is the ultimate question.
Certainly in Kiev for the days ahead.
You were hearing there about the acute
level of chaos
that may still yet be to become in
Russian top brass ranks,
whether or not the defense minister
and the head
of the Ukraine campaign end up
leaving their jobs.
Now, it is unclear at this stage
what level of turbulence
the move by violence
towards Moscow
has caused on the front lines.
Many argue
the vulnerable
not necessarily
involved in front line fighting.
Certainly those units
that made
that move were adequately prepared
and have
been away from the front for some time.
But what has this done to morale?
Certainly Ukraine is saying
they've managed
relatively obtuse by what they say here
to move forward one or two kilometers
on the outskirts of Baquba.
And today, they,
without any real specifics, suggests
that it had some progress
in the rear direction.
That's essentially
an Zakariya where many believe
and that southern area,
Ukraine wants to make a breakthrough
to the Crimean peninsula
occupied by Russia, off from Donbas
and the Russian mainland proper.
So suggestions that we might be seeing
some kind of progress,
but it's very hard to get specifics.
And I think to
a probably a sense of cautious
timing here among Ukrainian
military,
they don't want to move
necessarily too fast
without being fully apprized of
exactly how things have changed
along the front line.
But they certainly don't want to wait
so long for the chaos subside in Moscow
that that moment is indeed past
so utterly vital
that Kiev seizes this
moment for its benefit Jim.